My Puppy club
seems to have learned
what I was doing [Music] Ah ah ah I see here
because it has a collar and a bell I
'm missing this time
Next is a salamander a Sada
We're half-hearted  The head that protects the lobby Oh, needless
to
say, when is the answer
[music]
regulation
Well
this would have been a good experience
Many of them are annoying things that tempt you with sweet words
I'm
sorry I should have told you first, because
that's my role for you,
you're already my disciple, so rely on me.
Do you do it? Yanomori is easy
to get lost. Let's go home like this
[Music]
When we go home, we have to take care of that hand. It's
hard to leave a scar on my future wife
[Music]
Okumura
Who is who?  Didn't
you say that I bought you, of course, but I'm also going
to make you my wife